-Hanging out with
Camila Cabello, everybody.
Oh, my gosh, "Familia"
is out right now.
We're very excited.
-We actually messed up
on something, though.
-Oh? How?
-We totally should have gotten,
like, two tequila shots,
and just, like...
-And just went for it?
-Cheers.
Yes. My album is out.
Like what?
It's okay.
We'll do it backstage.
-No, no, no. Trust me,
this is the "Tonight Show."
There is booze in every corner
of this place.
-Just give us a damn shot.
-[ Laughs ] Come on,
let's do it.
-I deserve a shot.
-Yeah, you deserve a shot.
-You deserve a shot.
We all deserve shots!
[ Cheering ]
-They gotta drive home.
-No, yeah.
We'll figure something out.
We're talking about celebrating
moments
and how we do have to
appreciate moments.
-Yeah.
-I do like that you said that.
Because there are certain times
you kind of want to
shake yourself and be like,
"Hey, this is crazy
what's happening right now.
Enjoy this."
-This is significant.
-Yeah.
"Havana," which you performed
at our show,
which was one of our favorite
performances ever.
-I mean, by the way, that
performance literally changed
my career.
Like, I feel like the song blew
up after that performance.
-It was insane in the way it
looked, and the red.
It was just awesome and cool.
I just saw you certified
diamond.
-Yeah, what even is that?
[ Cheering ]
-What? Like, where?
Do you, like...?
-Like, I don't feel like my
brain can even compute
what that number is.
-That's -- No one --
This doesn't happen.
-Humans can't. We can't compute.
-That's wild.
-That's a lot of people.
-Also, you're so young.
You just started your career.
And you're, like --
this is, like, awesome stuff.
-It's only downhill from here.
-[ Laughs ] No, no.
No, it's nothing but better.
Oh, my gosh,
it's all great stuff.
-No, you know what? Listen.
-It's all uphill from here? I
guess you can't say that either.
-No, it is. No, it is.
Because here is the truth.
I don't know when, whatever,
another diamond thing --
it's very rare.
It's like lightning in a bottle.
I don't know when or if that's
going to happen to me again.
But I know it's uphill because
from that first album
to this album,
I am, like, so much happier.
I feel so much more, like,
creatively, like, happy.
And that's why, honestly, this
is -- this is my favorite album
that I've ever done, like, from
a songwriter,
songwriting perspective.
Like, I do feel
like it's uphill.
Maybe there won't be another
diamond,
but it's like I'm very --
emotionally --
-I think you're going have
a bunch of diamonds.
There's going to be just tons of
diamonds on this one.
You're doing
"Saturday Night Live" tomorrow.
I've seen you perform live
I don't know how many times.
Do you get nervous
that it's live,
or do you go, "No, this is --
I know how to perform."
Let me show you.
-I actually --
I love performing.
I find that one
"Saturday Night Live," like --
by the time I perform tomorrow,
that's usually, like,
when I'm in bed.
Like, that's usually, like,
when I'm asleep.
It's like midnight.
-Yeah.
-When I start,
and so having that amount of
nerves and excitement
and also being, like, sleepy
is, like,
a very confusing thing.
It's like having coffee and wine
at the same time.
-No, you won't be --
-It's like that.
-You'll be so amped up.
-No -- Well, I know.
But that's the thing.
It's, like, you're so amped up.
You're like somebody, please,
like, I need, like,
an exorcism of this anxiety.
But at the same time, I'm, like,
too tired to be this excited.
-It's the perfect --
-Right.
-And I'll tell you this much --
when you're done,
you're going wish
that you did it one more time.
-I agree.
-It's so fun.
You go, "Man, that was
the most fun ride ever."
-And congrats on everything.
-Yeah, I'm excited.
-You deserve nothing
but the best.
And I appreciate it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah!
Okay, first we got to get
a little lime.
-Yeah, alright.
-Ready?
-I mean, Stephen A Smith --
My apologies to
Stephen A. Smith.
-OK, wait, so this is what we
say.
This is what we say.
Pa arriba, pa abajo,
pa'l centro, pa'l dentro.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Wow, he chugged it.
-I assumed that you had just
put apple juice or something
in there, and nope.
That is real deal.
-Congrats!
You're drunk the rest
of the show.
-Whoo!
All right, party!
Camila Cabello,
"Familia" is out right now.
Check it out this weekend on
"Saturday Night Live."